the need to decriminalize of course is
what you write about in order to kind of
manage things that are now not being
managed by good people in other words
the criminal element is managing it but
is legalization necessary in order to
achieve that end well is
decriminalization is usually understood
Amanda you wouldn't be getting at the
illicit market at all remember Portugal
decriminalized all most of all
recreational drugs about 15 years ago
but all that means is that you're you
can have the drugs on your personal
possession and you can have up to 10
days of the drugs but you still have to
go to the illicit market there's still
no quality assurance there's no tax
revenue for government legalization and
regulation crosses that boundary and
says we're going to confront the illicit
market we're going to there's going to
be Quality Assurance and there's going
to be tax revenue and a full strategy of
harm reduction measures that's what
wrapped up for okay and we're obviously
headed down that path Bruce you have a
business that will capitalize off of the
legalization of this I guess I want to
ask you and I want to talk to both of
you about this because it feels as
though we've gone down this path for all
the right reasons but at the end of the
day Bruce you cannot claim to be selling
something that's good for anybody it's
bad for its users no matter what and how
do we square that how do you square it
that you're selling a product that will
harm people it's almost always a bad
idea to disagree with the host but there
is a reason that it's available
medically and and the reason is that the
courts in Canada to determine in fact
it's not bad for everybody there are
medicinal uses and so more of the harm I
would argue that comes out of the
current supply is the supplier because
they're selling more than just marijuana
and probably as your other guest
commented the fact that they can grow it
in any way they want that there's no
quality check so you want to get the
message out this isn't for everybody
isn't for no reason but you want to get
rid of the unknowns more as we're I
think more the harm accumulates
so I think that's a really good point
certainly medical marijuana has
well-established uses so I'll roll back
that part that it isn't good for anybody
but we know that this will we suspect I
should say that legalizing will
introduce a whole bunch of new users and
bring users out into the open in a new
way
have we had enough of a conversation
about the damage that that might do to
people well I think we have had a
conversation we're going to have to have
a continuing conversation because I can
assure you my focus is harm reduction
strategies and I think the task force in
fairness is very aware of that they said
the driver here is going to be public
health considerations so I think we're
in pretty good shape that way there
obviously will have to be more a
conversation and we're going to have
that conversation through the
parliamentary process we also know that
two of the provinces Manitoba and
Alberta said you know we need to slow
this down we need to take greater care
and I'm all for that
but at the end of the day I would agree
with your other guests I mean I think
legalization and regulation to quote the
economists is the least bad policy
because what we have now is not working
and causes great harm so Bruce and you
make the point that at the moment this
is a product that is being sold by bad
actors by illegal actors and that they
sell other things is it your expectation
that they will just get out of this
market and hand it over to to you
regulated folk in the in the open market
and no longer will that element be
involved or will you be competing with
that that portion of society yes I think
the competition the task force did a
pretty good job of balancing that right
so whatever we don't make doesn't mean
it won't be made it'll just be made by
the current sources and so they looked
at 18 is an earlier age than I think
many people expected but they recognized
that we need to not just say they won't
get it how do we get education to them
and so I think what you're going to find
is what tweed makes is going to be
understood to be sort of in a supply
chain that makes sense and that it'll be
to an audience that has to get educated
and their big obligation that's going to
land on the sector is about education
and that really it won't even just come
down to price if you have your choice
and you want to get cannabis you want to
get pot you have a choice to buy it from
a source that you know is legal and
what's in it for sure and so I think the
the migration will be to that for a lot
of people and that will be very hard on
the actors selling marijuana now this is
this is a group which is very
entrepreneurial so I'm sure
find other ills in society who fell but
I think marijuana is going to be tough
for them and I think enforcement is
going to be easier because it would be
really clear who is doing it legally and
who's doing it illegally well I want to
talk to you I want to ask both of you
Bruce I'm going to start with you this
is clearly still an unfolding situation
so you have some clarity today on on
where your business might go and there's
a lot of enthusiasm Christ into your
share price about what that means and
some would say a little over enthusiasm
but there's a lot of non clarity this
the things that may go one way or
another how do you manage your business
forward in the next sort of year however
long it takes without knowing for
instance where that where you'll be
selling what the final age might be
there's all kinds of uncertainty still
so we've started about two and a half
years ago having product available to
the medical market that markets gone
from zero patients to over a hundred
thousand now and the number of doctors
writing is growing so we have a very
good business in the medical business
but I think what people are probably
more excited about than just wrecking
Candida is the fact that as you pointed
at the beginning we're the first g7
country to tackle this we won't be the
last but if you're the company that's
the best at managing this policy
environment and becoming I'll call it
branded quality a trust equation that
resonates imagine next where this could
go but it'll be somewhere else in the g7
or g20 and tweet will be pretty well
situated I think to do that so I think
that the share price reflects the
medical now the wreck possible and the
International likelihood though he
raises one point that has kept some
investors certainly away from these
stocks and that is if you own it are you
suddenly a foul for instance US
Immigration you know if we know that
there that the legalization in some
place still puts you off side some other
jurisdictions well it does and you know
I think I agree with much much of what
the other guest has said I don't know
about the share price but you know in
terms of a wild card we have to think
about mr. Trump remember that marijuana
is still illegal at the federal level
yeah and his attorney general designate
is Jeff Sessions he said a couple of
months ago good people don't smoke
smoked marijuana so if mr. Trump of mr.
sessions decide that that this is part
of the new Trump land
that could cause a lot of discomfort
both for your your guests and his
corporation but also Canada and its
compliance with international covenants
most of which are on drug control much
of which are focused on prohibition so
we've got with that could be a real wild
card in terms of where this is going not
a lot of time Bruce but how do you
respond to that the concerns about the
fact that it remains illegal in the US
well I mean your new york studio I think
mr. Trump can actually hear me when I
speak because I'm not close to his
apartment I think what's really
happening is north of the border we're
following a process south of the border
it's federally illegal so I think really
what Canada's doing is proper and it
won't be caught up in cross-border if we
are a pharma company making something
not approved in the US but approved in
Canada would have no heartache same
thing for what's going to happen with
marijuana